versailles et guyancourt avec 90 minutes
pour continuer de rêver du stade de
france
mais à mon bord on sait le festival des
occasions manquées dominateurs dans
l'entrejeu les versaillais en bleus ne
concrétisent pas leurs nombreuses
situations à l'image de cette frappe non
cadrée de l'attaquant gregory l'effort
peu avant la demi-heure de jeu à maurice
baquet les joueurs de verrières le
buisson évoluant pourtant deux divisions
au dessus des guyancourt toit sont
dépassés par la vivacité
saint-quentinoise les essonniens
n'inquiète pas réellement le gardien
gluant courtois excepté sur ce coup de
pied arrêté à la mi temps toujours 0 0
stade langues auront pendant qu'à
guyancourt
les u19 prennent le contrôle de la
rencontre grâce à un but d'axel deal est
une réalisation logique au vu de la
domination saint-quentinoise au cours de
ce premier acte
l'exploit se dessine au fil des minutes
c'est à versailles que l'expression
match de coupe prend tout son sens au
retour des vestiaires le fcv continue
d'imposer son riz et comme souvent chez
les bleus le salut passe par grégory
lefort à la 78e minute de jeu le stade
mont boron s'embrase enfin avec cette
reprise de volée du pied droit de toute
beauté
mais à la 85e minute de jeu sur ce coup
de pied arrêté les joueurs de franck
bentolila moins bien physiquement
redescendre brutalement sur terre
direction les prolongations à lui en
course et la délivrance
les saint quentinois se qualifie
facilement pour la finale régionale de
gambardella
pendant que les seniors du fcv doivent
s'en remettre à la séance de tirs au but
qui pour l'occasion est un florilège de
tirs non cadrés ou d'un arrêt du gardien
à ce petit jeu les lilas s'en sortent
mieux plus l issue pour les bleus qui
pourront longtemps regretter leur manque
de réalisme
l'emploi doit se sentir bien seul
aujourd'hui mais un musée au monde plein
de bonheur